في طول كرم افاد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
بان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منعت سياره
اسعاف تابعه له من الوصول الى حاله مرضيه
في مخيم نور شمس الشرقي المدينه واطلقت
النار في الهواء رغم وجود تنسيق مع الصليب
الاحمر الدولي اشار الى ان قوات الاحتلال
تواصل اجتياحها الواسعه والمركزه على مخيم
نور شمس لليوم الثاني على التوالي اذ
اعلنته منطقه عسكريه وحضرت التجوال فيه
معنا من مخيم نور شمس شرقيه طولكرم مراسل
الجزيره ليث جعار ليث اذا جديد المشهد في
مخيم نور شمس حسب ما يصلكم من
معلومات نعم بالفعل العمليه العسكريه لا
تزال متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه لما يزيد عن
35 ساعه لا يزال خلالها او نفذ خلالها
الاحتلال حمله مداهمات واسعه في كافه
ارجاء مدينه او مخيم نور شمس خلال ذلك قام
الاحتلال باعتقال عدد من الفلسطينيين هنا
نرصد في هذا
المشهد السحب الدخانيه التي تخرج من عدد
من المنازل التي فجرها الاحتلال منذ
ساعات امس وحتى هذه اللحظه قوات الاحتلال
فجرت خمسه منازل على الاقل في مخيم نور
شمس تحت حجج ان هذه المنازل تعود لمقاومين
او او تلاحق
اصحاب حتى هذه اللحظه هؤلاء هذين المنزلين
الذين الذان يظهران في هذه الصوره قام
الاحتلال بتفجير بعد زرع عبوات ناسفه داخل
هذه المنازل ما ادى لاشتعال النيران بشكل
كامل فيهم على الجهه الاخرى وتواجد
للاليات
العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي لا تزال متواصله في كافه
ارجاء مخيم نور شمس حيث تشهد او يشهد
المخيم انفجارات واسعه بين الفينه والاخرى
وا استمرار لتحرك الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هذا المخيم لا يزال يواصل
الاحتلال ف عملياته العسكريه وسط انتشار
واسع للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه نرصد
في هذه الصوره التي تظهر عبر الهواء
مباشره تحديدا من المركز او احد المراكز
التجاريه في محيط مخيم نور شمس والذي حوله
الاحتلال لنقطه عسكريه اسرائيليه ت تتواجد
فيه عشرات الاليات العسكريه وايضا يعني
ايه التواجد المكثف ل جنود الاحتلال ويعني
قام الاحتلال بتحويله لايضام كز للتحقيق
الميداني حيث تم رصد منذ ساعات الامس
حالات اعتقال عديده فاقت الئ حاله اعتقال
تم الاستجواب بعضهم البعض افرج عنهم
والبعض الاخر لا يزال الاحتلال حتى هذه
اللحظه يعتقله وتم تحويله الى مراكز
التحقيق بالتزامن مع هذا الاقتحام وهذا
الانتشار الذي يظهر في هذه الصوره لا يز
الاحتلال في محيط مخيم طول كرم ايضا الذي
يشهد اشتباكات مسلحه وانفجارات متتاليه
بين الفينه والاخرى واستهداف للاليات
العسكريه امس كان هناك استهداف عدد من
الاليات العسكريه تم اعطاب بعض هذه
الاليات واليوم ومنذ ساعات الصباح قوات
الاحتلال قامت ب يعني ادخال جرافات
اسرائيليه وقامت بتدمير ل بنى التحتيه و
من شبكات الصرف الصحي وشبكات المياه على
العموم العمليه العسكريه لا تزال متواصله
حتى هذه اللحظه الانتشار المكثف لجيش
الاحتلال في كافه ارجاء المدينه لا يزال
متواصل حتى هذه اللحظه نسمع بين الفينه
والاخرى اشتباكات وانفجارات متتاليه في
محيط المخيم هذه الصور التي تظهر والتي لا
تزال مستمره للاليات العسكر
الاسرائيليه في المخيم هي تقوم بالفعل
بنقل الاسرى ونقل الجنود واحضار جنود جدد
من حاجز 104 او ما يسمى بتسني عوز غرب
المدينه وصولا الى هذه النقطه حيث تقوم
هذه الاليات بانزال عدد كبير من الجنود
وانزال عدد كبير من الجنود داخل مخيم نور
شمس ما يحدث داخل المخيم منذ الامس هو
حالات اقتحام واسعه لعدد كبير من المنازل
هناك يعني منازل تم تدميرها وفتح فوهات ما
بين المنزل
والاخر يقوم الاحتلال من خلالها بالعبور
هنا نرصد حاله من الانفجارات على ما يبدو
هناك او العاب ناريه يقوم الاحتلال او
الشبان
باستهداف طائرات الاحتلال المسيره وايضا
الاليات وجنود الاحتلال
من داخل مخيم نور شمس حيث تظهر في هذه
الصوره في هذه اللحظات بالتزامن مع
الاصوات الرصاص الذي يطلقه الاحتلال في
داخل هذا المخيم على ما يبدو انه استهداف
ل يعني المواطنين داخل هذا المخيم
بالتزامن
مع اشعال النيران او السحب الدخانيه التي
تخرج من هذه المنازل على وقع تفجير عدد من
المناز نازل اكثر من خمسه منازل تم
تفجيرها منذ ساعات الامس وحتى هذه اللحظه
في انحاء متفرقه من المخيم حاره المنشيه
التي تشهد منذ امس تحديدا حالات اشتباك
وانفجارات متتاليه واستهداف للاليات
العسكريه مجددا منذ الصباح ايضا في حاله
يعني حاله تاهب كبيره اليات الاحتلال تحوم
شوارع المدينه الاع
او استمرار الاعلان عن مخيم نور شمس نقطه
عسكريه مغلقه وحظر
التجوال هذا المخ التطورات معك ليث شكرا
لك كنت معنا من مخيم نور شمس في طول
كرم